the latest on the tragedy at a houston
concert that killed eight people rapper
travis scott continued to perform after
the declaration of a mass casualty event
the city's police chief had initially
defended his decision not to stop the
show immediately but yesterday he told a
different story lilia luciano has more
for roughly an hour a chaotic scene
raged at the astroworld music festival
friday night and the show continued for
almost 40 minutes after a mass casualty
event was declared now investigators are
trying to figure out why on wednesday
houston police chief troy finner said
his officers were in communication with
festival personnel the cpr was being
administered to multiple individuals he
later clarified on twitter that police
also told those in charge of the event
to shut down the performance the
ultimate authority to end the show is
with production
and the entertainer okay and that should
be through communication with
public service safety officials but on
saturday in the more immediate aftermath
of the festival finner defended the
decision to let the show continue and
said his department was part of that
choice
you cannot just close when you got 50
000 and over 50 000 individuals okay we
have to worry about riding and there was
a cooperation and discussion between
promoters
my fire department the police department
so i i think that part was was pretty
good
cbs news obtained video from a source
close to the astroworld music festival
appearing to show police near the stage
during scott's performance this video
was shot at around 10 pm with police
seemingly unaware of the severity of the
situation in the crowd some 20 minutes
after the mass casualty event was
declared the source says that means it
would be difficult for the performers to
know as well
we've reached out to the houston police
department for comment about those
images in the timeline and are yet to
hear back but late wednesday night
travis scott's attorney put out a
statement accusing city officials of
finger-pointing of sending inconsistent
messages and on backtracking from their
original statements gail
still a lot of questions there thank you
very much lilia